[Applause]
taking role involving Lucan porzingis
and the floaters get for Luca back down
work here for porzingis they come down
to the double into the shot clock look
at reigns it's late clock it is activity
to mate he's locked and loaded knocked
it down
let's trust Luca crowded by Sterling
Brown the all-time leader in games
played at convenient the straight works
out that loosen up the defense just
enough to get a look at that sliver of
space straight down that time step right
into that three after screen by Kleber
nothing but cord 27 the first half with
a preseason game special place
[Applause]
time is the only thing that can slow
down Luca da judge 55 Zander to get
anywhere he wants on the floor I think
is his biggest one of his biggest asset
as a player
the tallest two players in the NBA
porzingis and Mo Vaughn on the floor for
the mound right now
scores across a foul that's doing
whatever you want get the step backs and
get everything you want but this is
going to get it to knock opportunity to
get to the free-throw line a little bit
more when he's close to the basket it's
the first time in 13 career games
against Dallas the deal was on the side
of winning looking for three
is a talented kid and not hesitant to
throw up quickly that's the first miss
in 13 shots dodge hitch this
methodically gets to the rim stop chewy
think about what he's capable of doing
we saw it last year right here on this
floor
[Applause]
the first corner and on curry picked up
the loose ball shot clock at six seconds
for Luca I showed against Jamal Murray
one bounce dribble and a rainbow three
is on the money a thing of beauty a new
24 for the Mavericks Barrett is back to
the play so [ __ ] it I said that he was
[Applause]
at the other end has capitalized with
Luca Luca just attacking the lane
in Dallas three and three on the road
San Antonio one in Ford Lake o'clock
DeRozan closes out on finney-smith Lucas
step back over Murray yes sir
squander lead in that game lost by two
lost by five to Portland Luka shakes
free for the defendants in transit three
is going in tonight first with two shots
this is to pull up birdie would be
jealous
as Luca finds Dorian finney-smith that
was perfect oh my goodness
another guy not an easy path Benson jr.
big dog was the former number one
overall pick in the Milwaukee Bucks who
could easily has doctor takes another
one to go from best to the worst record
in the NBA and not because all these
guys left but because of injuries
obviously they lose durant and a couple
of the few players his table just takes
it to the rim my goodness I mean there
is just they're given
they're just overmatched right now they
got to find some spirit some energy and
Thompson and Durant and all those guys
[Music]
both teams on this one a team again
Lucas lamps it home to put Dallas on the
board first right but there's the first
defensive play by a presenters who has
been really doing policing the middle
this delay she was trying to get a lob
up to the basket by Tim Hardaway cute
[Music]
look it's on the board now good man down
to Fort Lee for Dallas now Luka Don
Cheech is on the board knocking down the
three off the screen fourth highest
scoring team in the NBA points a game
two and a half minutes in looking for
the first man what a shot it came from
Luca who tripped over lunge low ball but
appears to be okay
now Jackson hey is opposition porzingis
share is an extra passenger thank god
bernard a 40% three-point shooters roll
back to rolling dwight powell that pass
the putback detroit in front by five
now Lucho launches the three on our
truck
shot it better last year around 36 I
believe yep dancer Dorian finney-smith
does just that nice 23 in Toronto they
blew a 30-point lead and lost to the
Raptors 110 107 pocket why they play the
way they do they don't have the speed of
a Tony Parker inside to penetrate and
make it about this let me stop wait a
minute
psych got to go finish it by me yeah
that's the point guard don't get
laughing and smiling at the same time
say good pass it's very unique as an
offensive player can score a lot of
different ways with the Mavs Luke is
knocked down two threes from the left
side of the floor
that's just pop 50% over the last four
games on Golden State wins leaves
averaging 18 points in that time frame
like power doing a good job using his
hands that time defensively Drive in the
paint looking for their first basket and
they have it with a foul the boots
critical moment out of the timeout Luca
got trapped along the sideline got
himself out of trouble fires a three
oh great awareness by Luke good knowing
that the shot clock is low just gathered
up through rich one of two on the line
finney-smith committing a foul his first
talking with Rick before the game he did
stress
let's defensively for Brooklyn they went
into a zone but shooting over that was
Luka listens first offensive possession
isolated right side of the floor Luka
against bridges after bridges just
scored against Luca Luca will try take
it to the hole and he's on the board
[Applause]
this is a mismatch on every court there
is it looks great
[Applause]
with the rim rocking dunk an excellent
look at it from our incredible crew here
in Dallas Don Cheech flirts the FAL
benzidine
and I'll have a chance for 3 oz mattress
at the end of the day you've given up 54
points with 9 minutes ago in a second
you got to find a way to shut your mouth
and begin to play with intensity very
being very coachable wants to learn hard
worker
[Applause]
[Music]
eleven points for Damian Lillard Don
Cheech wanted a whistle
[Applause]
just take some basketball IQ knowing
that if a guy goes over top of the
screen he's chances are gonna run into
you trying to recover very heady play
right there by Luca Dante what are you
supposed to do here you're fighting over
top of the screen it was actually good
defense by Bazemore just pour of the
shooting start la is one pretend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the switch on defense Whiteside on
look at don't you that's a three
now remember he had eight threes in this
first matchup on Friday
33 125 win over Portland on Thursday
night and it's a steal looka than a
behind-the-back dribble Lisa pass plate
goes all the way to the cup see those
guys in less than a week why don't you
pay for Luca to the basket to throw it
down ain't open paint something you
don't see often against you talk no you
tall definitely a good defensive team
but nobody home on the week's top market
madathil the weight might go there
Dallas as it the public he was expecting
that fast play nice a tact here wide
open lane take it to the rack by Luca
now it's a drive-by kill just Alexander
and swatted Oh max ich liebe
that's a basket no foul for Dallas
look normally making passes like that or
the receiving in Lucas slam-dunk I took
likes fine big guy that's authority
cause his first basket and five shot
attempts from the floor
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
toss did the circus shot 12 count will
the foul as well
well Cory have one off Luther had two
and it uses the other one that's just
crazy focus circus is the right way to
explain that rolling for KP since
January 1st 10th to the league 1.75
[Applause]
just look too deep it's off liebe
finishes enough for the Atlanta Hawks to
be an all-star star 2 seconds left is
down
[Applause]
[Music]
good call miles he said that one up - oh
great look at it - off the glass the two
guards pretty bounce and it trip to the
free-throw line for Luka on the inside
against Walker here comes the rosin and
he throws it away although penetrated
into a crowd that has been really good
defensively challenging shots and that
time able to turn defense and - off that
he must come to life lukla top of the
way
thirty-six point third quarter for
Dallas with curry and porzingis two
outside things inside a beautiful bounce
and an exclamation put on the dirt
quarter by Dallas down to five on the
shot clock
what possibly is the last shot of the
third quarter
he uses right hand it's a block
well that's 30 points in the third
quarter felucca daunted with that three
corner opportunity for four points late
small lineups without Aldrich rebounded
by West to the game off the glass with
that injured right wrist he's six
percent from three the last couple of
games
Jamal cooking a little bit and this is
building on the tremendous February he
had this daunted finds Mariana vich
become just the third player ever
I mean it's absolutely incredible nice
pass by Luca Maxie gets behind the
defense and pretty finish
[Applause]